all right dylan you ready
let's do this
all right first question i have for you
is one just what's your general take so
far on bitcoin uh futures etf it just
literally got approved officially uh so
it's gonna start trading at the
beginning of next week what's your uh
what's your feeling on this
yeah i mean it's super bullish in my
opinion um i mean i would i would
preface it with saying i would never buy
the product um
but i think it's it's really bullish in
the sense that it unlocks a lot of uh
you know potential inflows from like you
know sort of the trap boomer capital
that that's out there um you know
there's just there's just so much you
know money in a zero yield negative
yield world uh real yield so so the
futures etf even though it's not spot
even though it's you know on the cme um
it's gonna unlock a lot of capital and
the kind of the second order effects of
that are really bullish in my opinion
got it and then in terms of uh when you
start to actually look at the um uh
bitcoin futures etf i'm assuming you
think the spot etf would be better
yeah um and i think one of the like kind
of bullish things about it is that i
think the spot etf is coming and this is
just like kind of the first first step
or the first domino um gensler and sec
has a lot of i mean there's a lot of
noise out there in the crypto markets in
general and i think they want to kind of
set a precedent here um with what's with
what's you know okay what's not um the
futures the cme is is very regulated
exchange and i you know some people say
it's market leading i don't believe that
at all um in the sense that it's paper
traded it's you know it's the legacy
hours of of trading but at the same time
um you know there is billions of dollars
of capital of open interest on this so
in the bitcoin futures contract so in
that sense um it's really good but yeah
physically settled or you know
physically settled bitcoin etf would be
far superior in my opinion got it and
we've got a couple of charts here from
you the first is looking at let's start
looking at the actual futures uh
interest itself we were talking a little
about some uh stuff but you've got a
couple of different ways to look at this
so bitcoin futures aggregated open
interest what exactly does that mean and
what are you seeing here
yeah so this is the total uh open
interest on the bitcoins uh futures cme
like lscme exchange so uh it's at
all-time highs and basically what it
means is just that the total amount of
like directional betting uh on the cme
has hit all-time highs so this for me
when i was i was looking at these charts
last week um the basis which kind of
blew out which we'll go over in a few
minutes um that was kind of one of the
leading indicators that hey like
something's happening under the surface
here um and maybe maybe you know smart
money or some insider trading was front
running this move i don't know if you
know that's insider so much is just kind
of uh you know front running the news
but yeah
open interest at all time highs in the
cme um that just kind of shows you that
there's a lot of demand here and i think
people are trying to front run that
becoming etf demand for for the futures
got it and so when you actually go ahead
and you look at the second chart that
you have here uh you've got this
annualized rolling one-month basis what
is this
yeah so basically what this means is
like so for any commodity when you hear
like a futures what that means is that
you know it's it's easier to think of it
not maybe in bitcoin but like say oil or
any traditional commodity right um
there's a there's a futures market so
you can buy the commodity today but also
you can um you can buy the commodity in
february of 2023 and there's a market
for that and there's a you know a price
for that so with bitcoin it's the same
thing there's there's a futures price
and so what this basis is is essentially
it's the difference between the spot
price today uh and the futures price
tomorrow but or next month or next year
but it's annualized so when the basis
says 20 uh you know annualized that
means that if you if you sell the
futures contract and buy spot uh on an
annualized basis you can get 20 yields
which is which is really significant um
in a again like a zero zero interest
rate environment um that's one of the
most bullish things about this is that
you know you're gonna have a way um you
know especially if there's some somewhat
of a better spot vehicle that comes to
market for traders for wall street for
legacy capital to come in and capture 20
yields uh when they can't get you know
when
bond yields are are negative in real
terms you're buying a junk bond at five
percent with inflation at six right like
it that doesn't make sense so you know a
lot of people even if they're agnostic
to crypto to bitcoin they don't care
20 percent yields make you make you wake
up
yeah and so when you start to think
about that macro environment like this
i'm fascinated by the fact that uh we
now have persistent inflation uh we've
got a ton of assets that either have
negative real rates of return or very
very atrocious uh real rates of return
more and more people are looking for
somewhere to store their value to
protect their purchasing power or to
have it appreciate bitcoin becomes this
attractive asset now we've got the
futures etf that appears to be likely uh
that is going to really open up access
uh to get exposure um and so all of that
leads to this push in demand supply 85
of it is illiquid uh over the last 90
days
do you think that this is just like pure
rocket fuel for bitcoin and we're likely
to see kind of what we saw in october
november of last year where there was
like a five six hundred percent increase
or just because the asset is bigger now
we're not likely to see that level of
volatility or that kind of severity of a
move
i think it's definitely possible like
bitcoin trades reflexively so in a bull
market you know like you'll kind of see
like this you know consolidation or
accumulation periods where like last
summer bitcoin did nothing for for
months on end while all this the stock
market and everything else was ripping
and then all of a sudden it goes
parabolic right um that's that's kind of
what on chain is like that's why it's so
valuable is you can see under the
surface there's a massive accumulation
occurrence which is happening today and
so you know like all-time high amount of
supply that hasn't moved in 90 days um
you know long-term holder supply at
all-time highs quantified a little
differently but same thing it's just we
have the supply squeeze going on and so
when something like a futures etf comes
in and even though they're not buying
spot bitcoin what it's doing is
if there's a large inflow into these
bitcoin futures contracts what it's
going to do is it's going to hike up
that basis it's going to raise the
futures price and what that's going to
do is it's going to incentivize capital
to come in and capture that you know
that spread that arbitrage and so you
know a lot of people like like there's a
lot of wall street that didn't care
about bitcoin at all but they bought
gbtc earlier in the year they went to
grayscale with massive amounts of money
because there was a huge premium and
they just wanted to capture the yield so
you know grayscale bought at 500 000
bitcoin because there was this huge
spread and wall street didn't care and
pummeled money into it and so i kind of
view this the the futures etf in a
similar sort of light in the sense that
you know itself like the futures etf it
might not be that bullish uh for the
spot price but what it does is it
incentivizes people to come in sell the
futures and buy the spot and so that's
you know the second order effect there
is is actually pretty powerful and i
think it could be a pretty big catalyst
if not just for narrative alone
got it and so when you think about this
last chart uh that you've got here is
the hbit
center index what the hell is this
where you find it yeah this is uh
uh i forget his last name uh one of the
bloomberg etf guys james he's been on
top of this he's uh he's a great follow
um in terms of just staying on top of
this stuff but basically this is over
the last year this is the spot price of
bitcoin uh and then this is like the
rolling futures if if you know they had
this sort of product which which you
know wasn't on the market but this is
the last year over year performance and
basically what you see is that the
futures etf underperformed uh just spot
bitcoin by 35 because of um you know
there's this uh contango right when
futures are trading above spot price you
have to you have to roll these futures
contracts over and so if you're
constantly buying a bus brought price
and then selling that contract the next
month and buying above spot price
because for the you know mostly bitcoin
futures trading contango they trade
above spot you're just kind of bleeding
money against bitcoin so like you buy
the futures etf and like bitcoin rips
and you're gonna you're gonna do all
right like you're gonna you're gonna do
very well actually but you're gonna
underperform bitcoin over a sustained
period of time which is why i you know
at the start said i would never buy this
because essentially you're just kind of
transferring some of your money to the
people that are going to come argue
they're going to arbitrage the spread
down and you're just going to kind of
bleed out money compared to spot
got it and so when you start to think
about the um this futures uh issue is
this mostly institutions that are coming
and buy it or are these actually uh
individual like retail investors are
gonna go try to buy this thing
yeah i think i think in general it's
just it's just good for the legitimacy
of bitcoin and in the eyes of of people
that have been skeptics for for a decade
right like you know you're gonna have a
lot of capital that's you know uh just
sitting in like in bond tranches and
these macro funds and they've ignored
bitcoin and they've laughed and they
called it speculative and now all of a
sudden there's an etf that's approved by
the sec they're saying bitcoin's here to
stay you have drone power last week
we're not going to ban it even though
they have no jurisdiction to ban it um
all these things it's just like you know
checking off like the fud boxes like oh
china ban like check off the box bitcoin
etf even if it's futures check off the
box and so you know now there's a huge
way to just kind of like an easy way for
people to allocate capital like
grayscale is a trust micro strategy is a
stock that you know that's levered
there's there's equity risk there well a
futures etf like you know if i want to
if i want to you know buy this during
some sort of mass macro risk off or if i
want to buy it as an inflation hedge you
know maybe i'm not going to hold this
for a year but there's literally
trillions of dollars of capital that now
has you know very easy access uh to
bitcoin uh you know its performance so
in that sense you know i think it's very
bullish um and i think it's you know
it's leading a spot etf that will
probably come in 2022. yeah and so what
is your thought process about this bull
market that we're going into right now
in terms of uh what is your price
prediction for the end of the year or
how high do you think that we can go in
the bull market
yeah uh you know tough question i love
it um i'm wearing 100k hat i think that
comes fast honestly once all-time high
breaks like people kind of gawk it at
big numbers but again like you have to
look at bitcoin in the log chart for a
reason um and when we break these
all-time highs i think it's going to be
similar to kind of the price action we
saw after uh 20k broke we flirted with
1920k for a little bit and then a month
after the all-time high broke we were at
40 000. so i think i mean maybe maybe
that doesn't repeat exactly but uh it's
going to trade it's going to trade very
very reflexively it's gonna go parabolic
and a lot of people that you know are
gonna kind of uh you know it's gonna
melt faces and so you're gonna have a
lot of capital you know flooding into
this this asset and you're gonna have
not a lot of people selling especially
early on so you know i think we're at
you know six figures or close to it by
the end of the year and i i i'm pretty
confident that it it's not just you know
gonna stop there um you know bitcoin is
here to stay i i completely agree do you
think that the bull market runs through
the end of the year or do you think
it'll actually extend into like q1q2 of
next year
yeah i think what a lot of people are
you know when you're comparing it to
2017 um just like the cycle by cycle
thing or by havings what people don't
really understand is we kind of had a
full bear market condensed into like
three months so we had you know we had
massive derivative liquidations
everybody that was leveraged even like
you know people are saying oh bitcoin
never goes down 50 of the bull market
i'll just 2x long everyone was wiped out
you had a massive minor capitulation
kind of engineered politically by china
you had a huge like puke up of spot uh
coins that you can literally see on
chain that were already accumulated so
we kind of had like you know this this
traditional like three year bear market
that we always have like or that
bitcoin's had you know a few times we
just saw that in like a pretty condensed
amount of time so i think you know in
that sense it's it's super bullish and
that we kind of just like charge back up
to run it back um so that's why i'm like
hey like you know we might not we might
not talk here in 90 days and i might
this this cycle
might not be so much of a traditional
four-year cycle and it might you know
continue to just run on as bitcoin is
you know now it's it's here to stay like
all these these fun like boxes that i
was saying were checked off well you
know everybody in the world is looking
at this thing you have presidents
tweeting about buying the dip like we're
in somewhat of a new paradigm here and i
hate saying this time is different but
in the sense of bitcoin's not going to
go down 80 and die for three years i'm
very confident in that so i think the
the tradition of a four-year cycle like
will said earlier uh you know i think
that that might go away
got it and so one of the things that if
we come back to this bitcoin futures etf
i think i saw uh raul paul uh who was
tweeting he was basically saying this
idea of uh issuing a bitcoin futures etf
it's a good step but basically handing
hedge funds a massive arbitrage
opportunity uh as the futures will trade
at a large premium in bowl phases and
then the hedge funds will get to capture
those returns and so he's saying that
it's an old financial market trick you
now have to add multiple new
intermediaries who all make profits the
etf provider the clearinghouse futures
broker administrator auditor law firm
cme and hedge fund arbs wall street gets
richer retail investors lose again like
is that your general read on how this
futures uh etf will kind of come into
the market and play
um yeah i mean more or less i think a
little less maybe not harsh but just i
think in general like a bitcoin futures
etf is better than sitting on xero or
sitting on nothing sitting on no
exposure like you know you should hold
your own keys you should you should buy
a spot bitcoin and you should self
custody you should do all the you know
best practices for being a bitcoin
holder but you know if you're sitting in
in some you know if you're if you're
like a legacy asset manager and you
couldn't have any exposure before well
you know this isn't a bad first step so
it is true that you know you're gonna
you're gonna underperform spot bitcoin
just because of you know the one percent
annual fee or i think it's like 90 basis
points um and this you know kind of
contago that you're going to bleed up
against because you have to roll this
thing over like we kind of covered um it
is true that people are going to come
barb this um but that's good because you
know that ultimately attracts more
capital and i think you know maybe not
in terms of the cne but when you're
talking about physically settled uh
futures contracts which means you know
bitcoin has to be delivered at a certain
date if i sell a futures contract i'm
promising to deliver that bitcoin i
think over time the most bullish thing
is we now have a fair cost of capital in
the in the market so so you know
interest rates everywhere manipulated
global central banks are going crazy
rates are negative they're letting
inflation run hot and keeping yields
basically pinned at zero um so everybody
that's that's basically like the cost of
capital is negative which doesn't make
any sense but now with with bitcoin you
have this global neutral apolitical uh
sovereign asset hard capped nobody can
manipulate it and now you have this free
market for the future you have like
basically a basically a cost of capital
that's free and open um and so cme yes
it's paper traded you can't put up
bitcoin as collateral these things are
are kinks that i think will be fixed
over time and i think we will get a
physical like a physically settled uh
futures market in the us but ultimately
that's you know the beauty of bitcoin is
now we have a free and open market for
money that no one can manipulate um and
so you know if if cme if there's some
sort of manipulation like the the gold
bugs say um you'll see that in the
difference between say darabit or ftx or
something with a real bitcoin futures
market with bitcoin you know delivery
versus you know cash cme so that that's
the most bullish aspect you know the
maturation of this asset class um is
something that's that's happening
gradually then suddenly um and so you
know these things even if it's not
perfect or are broadly very bullish joe
john what questions you guys got
dylan nice to meet you man i was uh i
got some some uh heat because i wasn't
on the show the last time you came here
so uh so nice to meet you meet you man
um my question follow
i appreciate that uh my question would
be like
what's the what's the biggest bold case
you can think of this year right like
we've heard some we've had some people
on uh the show that have said you know
numbers that i don't know if everyone
would agree with but they've approached
four or five six hundred thousand
dollars uh you know by the end of this
cycle kind of at the end of q1 or
sometime next year like if everything
goes right and in your mind what are
those things right like i think uh you
know other nation states adopting it as
legal tender whatever you want to call
it uh but like what's your biggest bold
case
yeah i mean it would probably be um
another kind of like michael sayler out
of nowhere where you just have someone
that's like all right i'm calling like
i'm calling the bluff i'm borrowing 10
billion dollars at two percent and and
you know because i'm this mega corp and
we're just stacking bitcoin or like you
know they've announced that hey we
acquired 75 000 bitcoin under the
surface while no one was paying
attention something like that where you
know kind of microstrategy came out of
nowhere last august um i think that
could potentially happen again i mean i
know for a fact that a lot of like funds
and and you know like so-called like
smart money uh that was very excited
about bitcoin at 60k um definitely you
know filled their bags at 30 40 50. um
but you know a public corporation or
some you know some kind of you know
macro fund with a without like say
bridgewater comes out with a with a huge
position ray dalio's fund like a 40
billion dollar fund if they said hey we
got a big bitcoin position something
like that could really ignite the mania
and and then you know price targets it's
it's impossible to time tops i i i'm
just you know i'm just dca's you know
and huddling for the most part i have
some option please because i i do think
that we're gonna see some uh some fun
numbers but you know in terms of timing
the topics it's near impossible but yeah
corporate adoption uh sovereign adoption
you know another another country like a
big country saying hey bitcoins legal
tender you know these things are are you
know just stepping stones and i have one
other question too off of we we talk
about uh the fomo stage a lot right of
like you know everyone's talking about
it and usually we gauge that on your
barber's talking about it asking
questions the taxi driver is asking
questions like from someone who studies
on chain metrics uh kind of all the time
like is there a a better way to
determine that fomo stage
yeah we're not there that's that's
that's awesome part um you know like
we're basically seeing like i was i
talked with will all the time and it's
like dude this we're seeing bull market
price action and the the on chain stuff
looks like we're you know in this
consolidation or like bear market phase
in the sense that like you see
these like things like long-term holder
spikes and the massive accumulation
during during like the bear market
during like the early the early months
of 2020 after the covet uh you know kind
of liquidation we saw just like massive
accumulation and that's what we're
seeing again and we're like you know a
few thousand dollars from all-time highs
so that's that's the crazy part is that
we're not seeing you know we're not
seeing this massive profit taking we're
not seeing toppy sort of things it's
like it it fully looks like we're about
to run it back and the the mania phase
hasn't started at all from the on-chain
side so even though even though it's
about to get crazy from a price
perspective um you know the underlying
like on chain metrics say this this
thing hasn't even started
john
what's up dylan
congrats
oh dill sorry congrats on passing 55
k followers on twitter you're now above
me but we haven't talked about that
um on your way on your way um so i'm
curious what have like has anything
surprised you in the last few weeks that
you've been looking at this stuff like
the
aggressiveness and the conviction of the
long-term holders like what has anything
surprised you when you've been looking
at the data
um i mean
not really in the sense that i guess
maybe just a price action like we we've
really run it back pretty fast um you
know we've been we've been saying like
you know accumulation's happening it's
once once this thing kind of snaps it'll
it'll go crazy but i i mean i i've been
very pleasantly surprised with just kind
of the the pace of this this bitcoin
price action um and it looks pretty
sustainable um it's not like we're
overheated uh the derivative markets
look fine like the macro uh kind of
risked off we've had not like risk off
but uh the decoration um with with
equities and other sort of traditional
assets is something that i was very
pleasantly surprised with i mean you
just look at the chart and it's pure
pure vertical accumulation for bitcoin
well well equities have sold off a
couple percentage points over the last
month and have lost momentum and then
those have been seemingly melting up
since since march of 2020 so that's the
most bullish side of things i think you
know when you when you're uh when you're
a risk manager all these guys you know
managing trillions of dollars of assets
combined they're all looking at their
screen and they see a c full of red and
they see bitcoin up eight percent i mean
that's meaningful and so you know like
for me or like for for the convicted
bitcoin holder maximalist correlations
and all that stuff don't matter but for
someone that's like managing these huge
pools of capital that just a few basis
points just a couple percent uh
allocation is gonna send bitcoin um you
know they're they're looking at this and
saying i need more exposure or i need to
get off zero so you know that's probably
the most uh surprising thing for me
pleasantly surprised
dylan give us a quick update on your
friends we've talked to will a million
times about like his friends in college
and stuff what are your friends saying
about it right now are they all uh
fomoing and really excited about bitcoin
do they not care are they not paying
attention what what is uh the the
general um uh kind of uh conversation
yeah i uh i live with a couple of like
uh my friends who um are all you know
they're holding bitcoin and some of them
are like very very orange killed but i'm
definitely known as the bitcoin guy so
you know go out to go out to the bars
and be like oh how's bitcoin and it's
like i've already talked about it for 10
hours a day so it's uh you know it's
good i think everybody is uh i mean some
are paying attention i've convinced a
lot of people to you know to get off
zero but i think uh you know for the
most part the the texts and calls and
and all that haven't started to flow in
so it seems like we're still in uh we're
in the early phase of this and then what
about your mom your mom's on twitter and
i saw that uh you've orange killed her
as well
yeah she she is very orange peeled um
she'll be she'll be pumped for that for
the shout out there yeah she's lurking
on twitter because i would always update
her about my day or what's happening and
she wouldn't know what's going on so i
just showed her how to use twitter and
she she's probably on it as much as i am
which is which is quite funny so i mean
it's awesome to be uh to be winning with
the fam
yeah for sure um all right so what is
your thought process in terms of uh the
bitcoin miners these publicly traded
companies it looks like more and more of
them are coming into uh the public
market we know that a lot of the hash
rate has shifted into the united states
and uh and texas specifically um and so
bitcoin continues to appreciate let's
say through the end of the year into
beginning of next year you know we're at
60 000 today we think you know six
figures of of bitcoin price you and i
both uh the miners obviously will do
very well uh because they have bitcoin
on the balance sheet their revenue is
going to go up because they're mining an
asset that continues to increase in
price do we feel like institutions are
going to come in and they're going to
start buying bitcoin and also start
buying those mining stocks and it pushes
those higher as well or how do you think
about the relationship between like the
publicly traded stocks to uh the actual
asset itself
yeah so i i mean i think honestly like
during the you know the mania part of
the the bull marketer just during the
bull market in general these these
miners will rip um and you know i think
that's that's just very bullish like i
own a
tiny position just like a speculative
kind of play but i think uh when you're
looking at like a valuation for miners
if you're looking at in dollar terms
right like these are very attractive
businesses um you know they're they're
gonna their balance sheets are going to
explode um but if you're looking at it
like a bitcoin kind of uh lens i think
uh for the most part because there's
this super high um kind of multiple and
equity markets in general right it's all
stemming from this manipulated cost of
capital uh i think it's gonna be very
hard for these miners to outperform
bitcoin over the over the long term but
the most bullish aspect is that when you
have when you have all these mining
mining companies ipoint you know they're
getting access to the public cost of
capital in you know in these you know
public markets and so you know hut can
go out and and borrow at basically no no
cost because they're collateralized with
bitcoin um i think a marathon is is
teaming up with silvergate and they're a
fed member bank and so they're they're
bought they have a 100 million dollar
line of credit and and silver gets a fed
member bank
so they have access to like basically a
zero cost of capital and it's a no lot
like bitcoin collateralized lending is a
no loss business though every bank's
going to get in and all these bitcoin
miners are not selling really any of
their supply so that's the bullish thing
like in the early days you had to sell
to you know cover your electricity costs
capex optics
but now they don't have to do that
because of because of you know this
access to public markets which is which
is really bullish for price so i mean i
expect you know these bitcoin miners to
rip uh but i think over the long term
it's going to be very very challenging
to just outperform
the bitcoin the asset itself when you're
considering tax implications and all of
that
yeah the other piece of this that's uh
fascinating to me is uh most of the
miners have been miners right they only
stay in the mining business uh we've
seen companies like microstrategy tesla
square go ahead and put bitcoin on the
balance sheet but the only company that
i'm aware of that's publicly traded uh
that has bitcoin on the balance sheet
and is not doing exclusively mining is
square who's going after some of these
other types of uh financial services or
software related uh components to
bitcoin it feels like that's kind of a
greenfield opportunity like there's a
ton of people who could really go in and
say hey look we're gonna be a bitcoin
company we're gonna be publicly traded
but we're not just going to be in the
mining business we also want to get into
whether it's building consumer apps
enterprise software kind of all these
other features that seems like no one's
kind of become the leader in that area
yeah i mean that's coming i think like
the bitcoin standard um is you know it's
a gradually then suddenly type thing um
you're going to see a lot of um you know
micro strategy type things later on i
think michael saylor was was extremely
bold and you have to comment him for for
you know being a leader and a pioneer in
that sense in the public markets but
you're gonna see kind of a lot of people
like like do what squared it and just
dip their toe in um i think coinbase is
is taking 10 of all their revenue and
they're allocating uh to crypto assets
more broadly but they're allocating to
whatever the users hold so that's about
50 bitcoin on their platform so five
percent of coinbase's revenue is just
auto stacking bitcoin now and so you
know forever for any bitcoin company
that makes complete sense um and i know
like most you know private companies
that aren't publicly traded they're
already doing this but i think it'll
just you know for any company really
like especially oil and gas who i
suspect to get into bitcoin mining um
you know in the coming years it's
already happening under the surface um
you know expect bitcoin on the balance
especially if this accounting standards
change which currently they're not too
favorable but i think you know a lot of
these things will take time but you know
they'll get they'll get it all worked
out absolutely um are you changing
anything you're doing as we go up or are
you just continuing to stack sats put it
in uh kind of cold storage and chill
yeah i mean for the most part i like i i
don't i think it's it's very it's very
tough to time tops and especially when
you're factoring in capital gains and
all that so i mean yeah i'm just
continuing to stack and and my kind of
plan for this last year a year and a
half and and through the next decade is
any time i think bitcoin's falling apart
you know far too much and is is really
cheap i'll take on a little bit of
leverage and and you know ride the wave
back up but in terms of in terms of
selling i
you know i why would like michael saylor
would say you know if you're in
venezuela you're gonna you're gonna sell
take some profits off the table with
your dollars to enter the boulevard like
no it's not it's going up forever so
um you know i that's my strategy and i'm
pretty pretty happy and content with
that yeah i tend to think that that's a
a pretty good thing anything else from
uh from youtube geniuses from the peanut
gallery yeah the peanut gallery no hey
dylan you want to join their union they
got a union against me you want to join
yeah i mean
you didn't even have to hear the sales
pitch i like that but now i get credit
so i get all so beneficial
dylan we're about uh 15 to 20 strong so
far we're uh recruiting if you're
growing by the minute as well by the way
dylan you're probably too young you've
never seen a union this is an exact lie
that a union would tell that they have
15 to 20 people and they have two that
was no no let's clarify i think that was
a i i under promise there yeah it was a
low ball number i think we're probably
higher than that by now just wait till
we pay uh dues can be paid in bitcoin to
us
[Music]
you're not getting my stats
you guys ain't tricking anybody on this
show all right man listen where are
where can we send people to fund you uh
fund you on the internet
yeah you can find me at dylan leclair
underscore um i do the deep dive with
bitcoin magazine so we put together a
daily newsletter um and and we we just
actually we're transferring to sub stack
which i'm pretty excited for so you can
just
next to that subscribe thing at the
bottom of my profile you can check that
out uh we cover a lot of the stuff i
talked about today and you know the
on-chain stuff derivatives all that so
you know we try to keep uh on the edge
of these things so uh yeah you can find
me there i appreciate you having me on
awesome man well thank you so much for
doing this i just dropped your twitter
link in the chat here make sure you go
follow dylan he's at 55 000 followers
he's above john
will crossover joe i mean dylan and will
are coming in hot dogs
soon they're smoking both of you bitcoin
goes to 250 and uh dylan's gonna be
right on my ass
i don't think he'll mind that at all so
it's uh all good man thank you so much
for uh for coming on and uh we'll do it
again
appreciate you man yeah later buddy